hi space monkeys so we are back for me
free we wanted to share with you that
demonstration which is a mix between a
technological demonstration of the GN
gene that we call Voyager and the eject
your game with some gameplay elements so
here you can recognize the big
mothership that was in the in the
trailer of course it's not the same
level of quality this is a work in
progress assets but again we wanted to
share all these these materials with you
as you know the game is in development
we still have a lot of things to do but
it's cool to share with you where you we
are on that spaceship part so yeah you
the mothership is a it's like a home
house for the player that one is about
400 meters long and you can have your
crew inside of course your main
character but also your spaceships so if
you start in the game without anything
and you get your first spaceships
even if then later you have a larger
spaceship you can keep the smaller one
into the big model mothership that the
same thing for the crew if you start
with one or two member and you crew then
you can have them in your big mothership
letter that gameplay mechanic of what we
call the you know the Russian dolls so
bigger smaller into the bigger and then
your characters is very close to what we
add in fact in Beyond Good and Evil One
when the characters we are getting out
of the other craft so here we have that
monkey which is my playable main
character here but of course you in that
game in that you can select your
character and create your own character
just to give you a Phineas scale that
ship is about 20 meters
and the other one the mothership is
about 400 meters long I'm going to close
to it so that you can see the size so
one we have large spaceships like that
the good thing the interesting thing is
that there are there are a real level of
gameplay you can go inside you we have
in tires for the for those big
ingredients so imaging I'm at the
beginning of the game I'm starting the
game I have nothing but I am like you
know like in Beyond Good and Evil one
you start without anything and you have
to get some money to like lever up and
get get your first vehicles so imagine
I'm just delivering pizzas yeah it's
like a side quest or just a way among
men is to to get some money and then if
we pizzas to those those guys so imagine
it's not my spaceship that's the
beginning of the game and this could be
an interesting way to trigger the first
ingredients of the adventure because the
spaceship is a playable entire you can
get inside you can sell your pizza and
then instead of getting out of the ship
you could decide to explore the ship and
why not discover that there is some
slavery some human trafficking and
things like that the good thing is that
in being good and evil - like in the won
the first episode you can take pictures
so if I'm taking a picture of evidence
of the things I'm seeing in the game
then I can share those pictures with the
guys in the city for example and then we
can trigger I can trigger discussions
with those guys based on the picture ID
I took so that's a very interesting
mechanic that that that can create that
feeling that you can explore everything
and you can gather information and share
those informations with NPCs but also
between players another very interesting
theme here is the feeling of scale here
we know that the players are they will
explore everything they will want to go
everywhere so we need to handle large
scale
[Music]
ingredients like like that huge statue
where you can go very close to it and
you can look at all the details on the
statues and of course you can go inside
of that this kind of statue and you can
also get on top of it I just want to
show you something interesting about the
scale and the feeling of scale so I'm
going to land on the top of the statue
and you will realize how big it is so
[Music]
here we have a wonderful Vista and I
want to show you this I'm going to go
more in the developer edition mode I can
move the camera very easily and you can
really notice and understand the feeling
of scale when you look at that little
monkey on top of the big statue this is
just a part of the head of the statue
when you're already very small and it's
very tasting to understand the scale of
things here you see that the statue is
really really big
it's the statues about 700 meters high
and the very interesting thing again is
that in fact that statue which is big is
just into a big city that is very small
in fact compared to the continent here
the size of that big island and which is
a small part of a big planet so you
realize that you are just a little dot
on the deep palate which is in fact just
a small planet around the bigger one
which is a small dot in the big universe
so when we started that technology we
thought that we needed to handle that
feeling of scale and in a realistic way
before going into details we wanted to
make sure that the engine was a capable
of handling this kind of thing when you
look at this sunset it's not exactly a
sunset a maid bar are made by artists
it's really the combinations of physical
ingredients you know the light that is
changing depending on the atmosphere so
you can see here the different colors
and the fact that of course the
planet is rotating around in space
around the big planet so yeah I'm doing
a kind of time-lapse I'm modifying the
time so that you can understand better
how it's worked you see that everything
is turning like in you know in a real
solar system well yes I'm increasing the
speed you see the night ear if the
cities so another important thing is
that you can at any time you can go
everywhere so which I'm going into
another city there is no lodgings and
fixer that everything is seamless
because it handles that big universe in
a consistent way there is no no [ __ ] off
inside that you can really appreciate
the point of view wherever you are it
will be the same mechanics so that was
one of the big feature we wanted to make
sure that we had before
showing the game to the public to
everybody so that we we wanted to make
sure that the technology was working
under this big ambitious game was
feasible
am I going I'm go back I'm going back to
my special one just to show you some
gameplay ingredients I'm going to change
a little bit of time so that we have a
bit more Sun yeah so that spaceship is
very very nice it's very close to Beluga
we add in Beyond Good and Evil 1 it can
handle very large villages it's also
very easy to do loopings and trigger
very fast movements so it's a dog
fighter I can increase the speed so this
is a classic plane speed we have on
earth we are about 1,000 kilometers per
hour but you can increase that speed
dramatically
like this for example and you will see
the speed is increasing now you see that
it's about five kilometers per hour
let's go back in the city so that we can
really understand the speed and I can
increase the speed again we'll use some
tricks movements and then we are going
to do a looping example so you can
combine anything any movements and the
very nice thing too is that you can even
increase the speed to 20,000 kilometers
per hour which is a lot I'm going to try
yeah to drift like that so at any time
you can you have the drifting mode you
have the all these very interesting
movements but of course the the biggest
things you want to do in this kind of a
situation is to go in space so let's
figure I owe speed and you see this
little effect around the spaceship is
because of the friction of the
atmosphere if I don't increase my speed
there is no reason to have more friction
but if I'm increasing the speed you see
that the effect is stronger and same
thing if I'm going very very fast so
depending on the quantity of atmosphere
you can have a stronger effect
until you start burning
but you see with those very high speed
you can really travel very very far and
very fast just changing the time of the
simulation that we can appreciate a
wonderful huge space so if I decide to
go in this planet or the satellite which
is somewhere around there I can I can go
down seamlessly and the more the further
you are of the planet the faster you can
go because there's no more atmosphere so
no more friction so easy as yes there've
a little friction but of course you can
go back onto the planet whenever you
want
[Music]
a very interesting thing too is that
there's a lot of biomes on the planet
like this desert or your frozen lands on
the planet different cities so we don't
want empty planets we want planets with
long marks with places to explore there
are non things where you have some monks
living there so they are not empty a
refugee planet that the planets we aim
to to work on to this to make our our
planets with life and the planet itself
is living somehow
for example that planet is different
different I would say but big biomes
because that planet as I told you with a
satellite of the bigger one the one that
is in the foreground a part of that
planet is a protected like you know like
the moon our moon is a part of the moon
is protected by her from the big
asteroids and meteorites
so yeah that's exactly the same thing
the cities are built in the safe place
where nothing is falling from from space
but I will show you a bit later the
opposite part of that planet where you
can have real time giant meteor rates
asteroids falling and modifying the the
planets ground
a very interesting thing is that this
this kind of event is connected to the
life on the planet so that yes you've
got those cities on the safe place but
once the big giant meteor rates are
falling on the other side of the planet
then you have the big companies that are
sending the slaves on those very
dangerous place and a lot of slaves are
dying trying to gather the meteor it's
good you know the older the things that
are falling from from the from space and
crashing they are taking those rare
materials and risking their life so it's
not just about the planet on on one side
and the story on the other one the
planet and the story are connected and
that that's a very important thing for
us so again let's let's look at that
planet modification process okay so now
we are back on the the other side of the
planet the side that is bombarded by
meteorites here we just want to showcase
the ability that we have in the engine
to modify the whole planet in real time
so here for example imagine that you're
flying over that region you can have a
huge meteorite falling in front of you
and you will have all these incredible
effects on the planet but also on the
other spaceships so that's a very
important feature for being good and
evil we want interactivity to be the
heart of the whole experience not just
with character not just with spaceships
but also with a big huge planet so thank
you for watching that that video this is
a our first space monkey debrief many
more will come and we would love to have
you leaving us your comments on this
space monkey program site so please come
and tell us what you think and expect
way more videos like that thank you very
much
you